howie roseman the eagles gm also spoke
yesterday as the eagles turned the page
from carson wentz to jalen hurts plus
whoever nick ciriani the new head coach
spoke as well here's a little something
from both of them about the most
important position on their football
team
like coach said um
and he reminds me daily we only have one
quarterback on our roster so it's
definitely not going to stay that way
and we've always
tried to value that position and to have
depth at that position and
um i don't see any of that changing here
as we go forward that's nothing that
that we would be comfortable with we
want to have a really strong quarterback
room we feel like um we have incredible
coaches
on the offensive side of the ball and
defensive side of the ball who can
maximize quarterback play and so
um we're going to look at the free agent
market we're going to look at the trade
market and we're certainly going to look
at the draft to try to strengthen that
position we feel like good offensive
football is catering to your players
particularly first and for and foremost
your quarterback so of course we're
looking at different things uh that that
you know that fit our offensive scheme
but then also what our quarterbacks do
well and and you know right now our
quarterback on our team all right we
have one quarterback on our team so
we're thinking about jalen and and the
things that that he does well
the challenge for the eagles and i i
know there was a report not long ago
that jeffrey laurie the owner of the
team wants
hurts to be the guy and doesn't want
competition
um
the problem is you're sitting there with
the six pick in the draft are you
thinking about a quarterback
are you not thinking about a quarterback
well whatever you're thinking about you
want people to think the opposite if
you're not thinking a quarterback you
want people to think you are thinking
about a quarterback because you'd rather
have as many quarterbacks drafted as
possible before you're on the clock if
you are thinking of quarterbacks there
you want teams to think you're not so
maximum quarterbacks are on the board
when you're at number six so it's a
delicate time on the nfl calendar to be
saying anything
because every other team is scrutinizing
for any clue so they have the best idea
when they do their own internal mock
drafts who they think the eagles would
take at number six based on who goes at
one through five
bottom line though is miles it's a fact
the eagles value the backup quarterback
position they have learned unlike any
other team in recent years what it means
to have
a competent number two
because the competent number two steps
in whether it was football's version of
slumdog millionaire as i said last hour
with nick foles or something else you
put that guy in there and he leads you
to a super bowl so you have to and and
i've said this time and again you have
to the eagles view the backup
quarterback position as a top 15 spot on
their entire roster so they got to get
somebody else if hertz is the only guy
under contract and now the challenge is
who's it going to be and what kind of
backup is it the backup who
thinks he's competing to be the starter
or is it the backup who knows he's there
for one purpose and that is to help
jalen hurts be the best starter he can
be
well i don't know how many guys are like
that out there i guess alex smith would
be the one guy that like comes to mind
where it's back up but back up to
support jalen hurts and i'm sure that
there are probably other quarterbacks
still on the market but if there were
one guy that fits that mold i would have
to think that it's him but just i mean
from the standpoint if you have the
number six overall pick and there are
these quarterbacks who
it seems like there are four to six that
can really be successful or at least
that people seem to think can really be
successful in this league if you're at
number six overall
you have to do all the due diligence in
the world to say is this quarterback
ceiling higher than jalen hurts and if
the answer is yes then you probably have
to pick that guy at number six overall
or maybe you do the calculation and it's
you know what we think that we can get
we can trade up you know if we use our
sixth pick and then maybe the pick that
we're supposed to get from the colts or
whatever it is
and we can go up a couple spots and we
can get somebody that we think is going
to be much better than jalen hurts then
i think you have to do it that's how
important the quarterback position is so
they've got to do something at qb
obviously because as siriani said as
rosen said in those clips they only have
one quarterback on their roster right
now and that's jalen hurts so it depends
on really how siriani wants to construct
the offense and then how they evaluate
these qvs that are coming out in the
draft and who they could possibly get at
number six overall
i remember in 2016 it became clear that
the eagles were very serious about
carson wentz when jeffrey lurie became
directly involved in
visits pro days etc this year that can't
happen this year there aren't visits
this year i mean you can you can have a
limited group at the pro days you're not
going to have the private workouts i
don't believe that's always a very very
viable way to get more information about
a guy and get to the point where you're
comfortable i think the problem for the
eagles this year given that they've
number one traded carson wentz number
two
invested at least the short term in
jalen hurts
how do you get to the level of comfort
that you can upset the jalen hurts apple
cart
and bring in somebody at number six
because i think jeffrey lurie's not
going to authorize that pick
unless he feels damn comfortable about
the player that they would be taking and
supplanting jalen hurts and maybe making
jalen hurts a guy who's available in
trade somewhere in those 18 hours
between the end of round one and the
start of round two so i think that's the
practical impediment for the eagles it
it doesn't apply with the same weight to
these other teams because you're you
know there's three types of teams miles
teams that have franchise quarterbacks
and know it
teams that don't have franchise
quarterbacks and are desperately looking
to find one and the eagles are currently
in that third category which is we have
a guy
and we're not quite sure
which way it's gonna go
if you're not damn sure the guy you're
drafting at six is going to be your
franchise quarterback
you may be throwing one away
in the same year that you hand off
carson wentz to a spot where maybe he's
going to be as good as he was when he
was an mvp candidate
for someone that you haven't been able
to fully and properly vet i think that
to me
tells me and watch they're going to take
a quarterback with number six but that
tells me that they won't
well it's i think that point about not
being able to fully and properly vet the
quarterbacks at least as you normally
would in a non-pandemic year that
probably is going to have a lot of
effect because
i think the consequences of just what
the pandemic is right now is just so
interesting whether it's the depressed
cap and you know you see all these
veterans get caught and guys are just
taking short-term deals because they
think well especially now that we know
what the figures are from the t new tv
money everything is just going to
increase in a couple years and all that
it's very fascinating what this thing
might look like for these qbs coming out
because as we saw for trevor lawrence's
pro day urban meyer standing right there
right in front of him and that's
basically as close as he's going to be
able to get to trevor lawrence until he
picks trevor lawrence at number one
overall you're just not going to have
that same level of interaction where you
know you see guys going around in the
private plane from the owners and
they're working out this qb here and
then they're going to that qb there it's
just not the same when you're sitting
somewhere looking at a laptop or a
tablet or a phone and you're talking to
somebody over zoom it's just it's not
the same as being able to really put a
guy on the board one night and then the
next day you test him when he's out
there on the field on all the concepts
that you talked about so yeah it's gonna
be interesting to see
which teams are gonna say yes we want to
definitely draft a quarterback even if
we don't necessarily need it or we just
don't necessarily have that level of
vetting that we normally would and
that's why we're not going to do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports